hi everyone Carolyn here and I'm very
excited today to be joined by Mike
Biffle Mike is the creator of the game
Thomas was alone which a lot of us here
in the GameSpot offices were we're very
big fans of thank you and you're here in
town now as GDC is happening here in San
Francisco to show off your your new game
volume so I don't actually know a whole
lot about volume myself I know that it's
a it's a stealth game but why don't we
just kind of jump right in and take a
look at it and you can kind of tell us
all about it
cool I'm so yeah this is volume um it's
a it's a stealth game I guess as you can
see from the vision cone of the guy down
the bottom there with far too small text
I need to make bigger at some point this
is an early build it really is very yes
it's very work-in-progress
so it's basically it's it's a kind of
old-school I guess in I mean like
immediately Ramon reminded of the
original like Metal Gear Solid from this
perspective and the vision cones
you know reminiscent of the radar that
you had in that game yeah so maybe
certainly some old-school stealth roots
here definitely well I mean that was I
was obsessed with el gusano go solid and
Deus Ex will basically mike to share
kind of childhood games that i lived off
of i still remember being handed the the
Metal Gear Solid's disc by a friend of
my dad's okay going a bit crazy for it
yes so um so it's it's is a callback to
those games it's kind of it's it's
old-school stealth with that kind of
immediate understanding so you know
exactly where everyone is you know
what's going on yeah there's a lot of
ambiguity and stuff which is cool but I
wanted to make a game way your awesome
way Oh like the cleverest guy in the
room
Jerrica working stuff out um and this is
this is a bad guy so here I'm just kind
of avoiding him right basically every
mission you have to get through a space
and collect all the gems these kind of
spinning things sure and then next up is
and you go through it so it's that
simple
and then you complete a look alright and
then the bug happens and the characters
drawn slightly over to left that's why
we go keep going yeah
so but what where it gets interesting is
it's really a game about crowd control
there's no killing so you can't go up
behind someone you can't sneak up behind
someone salad sneaks out yeah yeah which
is great which is which is cool but I
know it's when I play stealth game so I
play every stealth getting because I'm a
massive self geek I just realized I was
playing them all the same way I was just
basically room clearing just going
around the room taking everyone else
share which is fine and I'm not against
that but it just kind of felt like I had
all these interesting mechanics and I
couldn't yeah I wasn't using any of them
because I found the one that was really
powerful which used to just kill
everyone um so in this game you can't
you can't actually do that you cannot
directly stop an enemy you can't even do
the Batman thing of kind of the stylized
takedowns where you kind of get away
where it's not really killing but your
Vista lab action sure so it really
becomes about crowd control and about
navigating the space and staying out the
way of bad guys which is which is
hopefully interesting and you do that
with lots of room interactions which
I'll get to in a second but also this
kind of thing which is the which is this
tool here which is kind of a guided
noise maker you're using sound in order
to trick enemies you can do things like
you can get temporarily invisible you
can wear a disguise that makes them
think you're one of them and that kind
of stuff okay kind of trying to abstract
down all the cool little stealth
mechanics from you know games like
hitman the Metal Gear Solid all these
games I adore and just trying to pull
them right back to their simplest
version so with this this is a
noisemaker so you press the button
what's the trigger once to launch a
noisemaker Oh press it again that makes
noise okay and anything within that
circle of effect it is going to come and
investigate what happened so it's here
we have a situation where I pick up all
these gems I will see this guy here he's
right in front he's a really good guard
he's a surprisingly good guard most
stealth game guards walk away give me a
little break but this guy he's watching
it so I want to get past him if he sees
me I'm in trouble so I'm going to make a
noise behind him
I'm completely okay so I'm gonna run
away and distract him over there there
we go back to where he was yeah oh he's
cool so I'm gonna try and do that
successfully okay we've seen you were
demonstrating the wrong way to do this
is that yeah you're gonna demonstrate
the right way so that's just good go
over there I guess he saw me but it was
over yeah
so I'm gonna load up a more advanced
level now so this is just because cuz
those guys show the mechanics and that
you'll do a few levels like that which
kind of tutorial stuff but then you'll
get into these kind of much bigger
environments where you have multiple
characters moving around we're gonna use
the same gadget we were using before
just so you can kind of see how we how
we do things but we have to go and clear
those gems so yeah now I'm going to fail
massively on my own level here and
embarrass myself but this is quite
straightforward these are force fields
which which enemies can go through but
you can't unless you deactivate which
takes a little bit of time so kind of
slows your progress yeah go through that
side fine okay yeah so he can't see me
because I'm behind that wall and then I
have two more brilliant guards here
blocking they are they're doing their
job properly yeah but they have like
loads of gems behind them and I want
those gems because I'm a master thief so
I'm gonna I'm gonna kind of leave them
out so I'm gonna use the noisemaker to
make a couple of noises in quick
succession sure so that's first noise in
this gap here so they'll come out that
far then I'm gonna make a noise over
here still going investigate that and
sneak in behind them kind of scooby-doo
like just stay here then go back to
where they were yeah and I can use the
same kind of trick to play them out this
far
get in this locker here now we're
missing we're missing few animations the
locker will open we'll have some stuff
the animators doing some really cool
work on that right now but yeah so it's
it's really about using that space
you're never going to leave a level with
less enemies than you went in with it
into it with which is kind of the point
yeah and but that makes it interesting
it means you're always on your toes
there's very few safe areas you're
always at risk you always have to use
things kind of intelligently to get
through environment do you want to talk
at all about like the sort of story or
like where they where this is taking
place what what's going on here okay so
I'm just gonna get killed first okay but
it gives me a chance to show the very
quick reloads there we go which is good
in the staff game um so I'm gonna keep
trying to play but I'm probably I play
badly because I'm gonna be talking um so
no it's some it's the idea with the
story was I was I was I kind of sat down
I knew I wanted to tell a cool story
Thomas was alone a lot of people like
Thomas was alone specifically for the
story yeah so I kind of wanted to make
sure I did a cool job with the story so
I kind of started doing research and
thinking okay so I want to make a
stealth game which kind of means I want
him to be a thief but you know obviously
thief exists so I want to make sure I
get that right I'm gonna get scene
whatever oh no but now he's coming to
investigate oh so I knew I wanted to do
I'm gonna keep those distracted so you
always do things so I started thinking
about thieves in history and how stories
about thieves are told and Robin Hood
was one that came up quite quickly sure
and I was kind of thinking about doing a
Robin Hood game I'm gonna need to get
sorry I'm gonna need to get someone to
quickly come out and and click GDC
quadrants for me now and do that I
wanted to do a Robin Hood story um but I
wanted to do a cool Robin Hood story so
I decided to do a kind of a near future
modern Robin Hood and it's the idea of
what would Robin Hood be nowadays if
Robin Hood was to emerge now what would
what would that character do in order to
kind of rob from the rich and give to
the poor and for some reason I was
watching a lot of YouTube videos and I
kind of thought well actually that might
be something where someone would
actually go on YouTube or on Twitch and
like stream and start showing the world
how to be better thieves yeah
so he's kind of that's the idea is that
that's the job he's doing is kind of
streaming these these these videos of
crimes he's found basically an enemy
training system used by the bad guys and
he's using it to show the world how to
rob from their crowd sourcing it so it
all takes place in this one in this one
room really which is this kind of
installation that you found
but yeah you run around in these virtual
environments recreating crimes we've got
a really cool cast Danny Wallace is back
who was the AI in he who's playing the
AI and this he was the narrator Ian
Thomas was alone and he's he's cool he's
playing the kind of the mr. paperclip
exactly so he's he's been made by the
bad guys to kind of teach you how to be
an amazing mercenary but you're kind of
trying not to do that so you kind of
have a cool little conflict there and
then we've got some very cool people
playing and Locksley's played by Keiko
Charlie McDonnell who's a big youtuber
who's really charming wonderful fella
and then the cool guy playing the
villain I can't talk about yeah but yeah
it's it's kind of it's coming together
oh I don't think oh sorry I'm just stuck
or someone hey can you click GDC
quarters for us thank you I'm so just
going to show a few other gadgets in the
game cool sorry about the problems by
the way viewers I'm this is a slightly
buggy build but this is a different map
I'm just going to show you a couple of
other gadgets before I show you some
other stuff so we've got here the folly
Molly okay now the folly is a tripwire
ah so you can place it in there when
they run over it it'll stun them but not
for very long so you'll see there he's
only gonna be stunned for a matter of
seconds really and then he'll wake up
and he's not gonna be happy he's gonna
invest able when I talk about quickly
cuz it's a stealth game
yeah and just one more other thing is
the huge and I think I'm going to show
you the editor because the other thing
about this game that's quite interesting
is that every level in the game I've
shown so far is made in a
in a specific editor that was made for
this game in particular so this is I'll
just quickly show you the viewed is a
noise maker like before but instead of
being bouncy this one sticks to a wall
and can be used as a timed thing that's
a that's a straight-out deus ex that's
that's my favorite the grenades and Deus
Ex were fantastic you can kind of launch
them at things and distract people
anyway what I want to show you now is
the editor so this is what we're working
on the big of the big push with this
game was I I wanted players to be able
to keep playing it so we Thomas was
alone Thomas Malone was a kind of a kind
of two to three hour single-player game
you play it through once hopefully you
enjoyed it and had a good time with the
story but but you were done about sure I
wanted to make something that players
could kind of keep playing over and over
if they wanted stealth levels once
you've beaten a stealth level it's not
particularly fun necessarily go back and
do it again because you have worked out
the trick to that level so putting an
editor seemed to work procedural doesn't
really work or it was hard to make work
because procedural tends to rely on
combat and it's hard to get a good
stealth level without that someone
designing it so I thought I'd let
players design their levels so you've
got here this is the tool I use to make
my levels and players will have exactly
- the same - all absolutely
III find that the best way to design an
editor is to make it for yourself and
yeah so just are things like come with
the walls it used to be you had to click
every time you wanted to place a wall
right that got really frustrating and
horrible so now it's a drag which is
just I know that's a really small thing
but it's the kind of stuff I mean that
can save you a lot of time and that's it
a lot more convenient and hopefully and
hopefully players will kind of benefit
from me hitting my head against the wall
trying to make it fun I can't show you
some of the features of this because
unfortunately I'm I've not got the I've
not got the mouse in front of me and
it's a little bit buggy at the moment
but you can you can recolor things you
can change things to look the way you
want and can very quickly start playing
the level you're making and see how I
play and I'll be
shareable absolutely yeah so you you
they'll be saved on the server you can
upload any maps you make share them with
friends share them with non friends well
I've said setting each other to each
other challenges and I want people to
kind of create stuff for this game going
forwards that kind of enhances the game
and gives people more stuff to do the
other cool thing is the way the story is
told is via a voiceover and it's
actually made in such a way that it can
work overlying levels I didn't make so
so if you want to get the so let's say
the game comes out and maybe a few
months after it's out you want to play
the game but you don't want to play any
levels I've made you want to just play
stuff that the communities made you can
do that and you'll still get the story
experience which is cool so I kind of
want to ensure that I love there's the
stories about a vampire the masquerade
bloodlines where it's like been made by
the mod community and remade and don't
do stuff I love the idea of a version of
volume in the future that people like
more than my version that's right I
think that's really cool like I'm not
really interesting as a designer to play
with that yeah something out into the
world and then people can sort of make
it their own this is the hope so we'll
see we're playing with it and it's
coming together so it's coming to a
specific platform it is it's coming to a
PlayStation 4 and Vita first okay and
then about a month later we'll be doing
a PC mark steam OS port and then who
knows from there wherever wherever once
it really and when when will people be
able play volume um we're hoping by the
end of the year maybe maybe into next
year a little bit if it needs to be um
the great thing about Thomas was alone
was lots of people bought it and it
means that we've got the time to make
the exact game we want to make and take
our time really so we can kind of have
the attitude of we'll release it when
it's ready which is which is kind of a
game developers dream to not have to
rush to kind of get stuff done exactly
how we want absolutely well Mike thank
you so much for taking the time to come
in and give us a look at volume today
thank you for Andy yeah thanks very much
for watching folks we'll see you later